Hi my name's Michelle, I run Lab Muffin
Beauty Science, I have a PhD in chemistry
I'm a skincare nerd, and I'm an acid
addict. Not that type of acid, I'm talking
about skincare acids! Today I'm going to
be talking about some of the best acid
ingredients that you can find in
skincare.
In chemistry an acid is a substance that donates H+, also called a proton.
When I say the word "acid", you're probably thinking of bubbling test tubes, chemical burns,
melting skin... but the right acid ingredients used in the right amounts can be really beneficial for
your skin! In fact your skin is naturally
acidic thanks to the acids in your sweat
and the fatty acids released from sebum,
the oil that your skin naturally
produces. The thin film of acidic goop
on your skin is called the acid mantle.
It's really important for keeping the
right balance of bacteria and other
microorganisms on your skin, so that the
friendly microbes are happy and the
harmful ones can't get too much traction.
The pH of your skin should be somewhere
between 4 and 6. Let's get started on my
favourite acids. Alpha hydroxy acids or AHAs
are ingredients that have a hydroxy
or OH group on the carbon next to an
acid or COOH group. Because of this
positioning AHAs have a special
property: they can help your skin
exfoliate. The top 10 to 20 layers of
cells in your skin are dead. Around one
new layer of cells is produced every day
so one layer needs to come off or
desquamate
to keep your skin in equilibrium. If it
doesn't come off properly you end up
with dull flaky rough skin. Lots of
things can go wrong with desquamation.
For example dehydrated skin that lacks
water doesn't come off properly. Your
skin turnover also slows down as you
get older. Alpha hydroxy acids help
loosen skin cells so that they come
off more easily. It's not 100%
established exactly how AHAs
do this, but so far we think that they
bind to calcium ions which makes the
dead skin cells break up. The dead skin
cells come off more easily and in
smaller, less noticeable pieces. This
means you end up with smooth clear
glowing skin. AHAs also change other
aspects of how skin works: it increases
skin-plumping collagen and increases the
proportion of younger cells in your skin.
AHAs also reduce fine lines, prevent
acne, fade dark spots, increase skin
thickness, and even out skin tone and
texture. They also act as humectant
moisturisers that help your skin hold
onto water. There are a whole bunch of
different AHAs that can help your skin
out and they all have different
properties. My favourite so far are
glycolic acid, lactic acid and mandelic
acid.
Glycolic acid is the smallest and most popular of the alpha hydroxy acids. It was my first AHA and I was so
impressed when I tried it. I tried a
sample of Paula's Choice 8% AHA Gel
overnight and the next morning my skin
was smooth, plump and glowing. Since
glycolic acid is the smallest AHA it
gets into the skin more easily and more
deeply than other AHAs. This means
that it will usually be more effective
but it can also have more side effects.
Glycolic acid is the most irritating
of the alpha hydroxy acids. It also has
the most research to back it up. It's the
active ingredient in a whole bunch of
cult skincare products including P50
Lotion, Alpha H Liquid Gold and Pixi
Glow Tonic. It's also commonly used in
peels for treating acne and pigmentation,
sometimes along with microdermabrasion
or microneedling. If you're starting on
a glycolic acid product I would
recommend a leave-on product that's got
lower than 10% concentration and a pH
under 4 or 5. You should also use
sunscreen when you're using glycolic
acid since it makes your skin more prone
to sun damage even when it's not on your
skin. You can use it in the morning or at
night. If you want to find out more about
pH and acids, you can check out my older video on pH and pKa.
Lactic acid is the best researched
alpha hydroxy acid after glycolic acid
and it's my current favorite and I use
all of these products. Lactic acid is
notable for being gentler, more hydrating
and more effective at treating sun
damaged skin. It also increases the
ceramides in your skin. Ceramides are one
of the three oily lipids in your skin
that's important in keeping your skin
waterproof so your skin will stay
hydrated.
Like with glycolic acid I would
recommend starting with a leave-on
product with less than 10% lactic acid
and a pH of 4 or 5, if you haven't tried
any alpha hydroxy acids before. Lactic
acid is also in yogurt but it's usually
at less than 1%, so yogurt masks won't be
anywhere near as effective as a leave-on product.
Mandelic acid is another alpha
hydroxy acid and I've only recently
started using it in this For Beloved
One product. It's only really been
studied in peels but it works a lot like
glycolic and lactic acids. Because it's
quite a bit larger than glycolic and
lactic acids, mandelic acid doesn't
penetrate as deeply so it's even less
irritating and has a more even effect in
peels. In peels it's commonly recommended
for ethnic skin that's more prone to
rebound hyperpigmentation, which is when
an irritating treatment makes your skin more pigmented.
Salicylic acid is a really popular anti acne treatment.
It comes from willow bark and is
structurally related to aspirin so it's
got anti-inflammatory properties. It's
also commonly referred to as a beta
hydroxy acid. Much like alpha hydroxy
acids if can exfoliate your skin and
keep your pores clear, reducing acne. You
can find salicylic acid in lots of
products like serums, spot treatments and cleansers. It's usually at a concentration
of 0.5 to 2 percent, although in
spot treatments it's usually higher. It's
also used in high concentration in peels
for treating acne, acne scars,
pigmentation, sun damage and age spots. You can also
find it in wart and corn removers.
There's some evidence that pH isn't all
that important for salicylic acid
products, so if you want less irritation
you can try a higher pH treatment.
Azelaic acid is one of the key
ingredients in lots of prescription-only
acne creams. It's usually at 15 to 20
percent.
There aren't many side effects to
azelaic acid unless your skin is very
sensitive, in which case it can give you
a little bit of stinging, redness and
peeling. You can also use azelaic acid
to fade pigmentation, like post-acne
marks, the brown marks that are left on
your skin after you've had a pimple, also
known as post-inflammatory
hyperpigmentation or PIH. In combination
with retinoids, azelaic acid can work
almost as well as hydroquinone.
Retinoic acid is better known as tretinoin.
It's the active ingredient in creams like
Retin-a and Renova. It is THE gold standard
of anti-acne and
anti-aging treatments. It's a form of
vitamin A and it's backed up by tons and
tons of studies. Tretinoin works by
reducing clogged pores so you end up
with less acne. It also increases the
amount of collagen in your skin, which
means it prevents wrinkles. It's also
handy for fading dark spots. Tretinoin
is super awesome but it's also really
irritating so when you use it a lot of
people end up with red flaky itchy skin.
It also causes purging. You can find
tretinoin's weaker cousin retinol in
lots of skin care products like this one.
It's less effective but it's also a lot
less irritating.
Ascorbic acid is the most common water-soluble form of vitamin C. It's also the best researched
version. Vitamin C has a whole bunch of
awesome benefits for your skin like
treating pigmentation and increasing
collagen. Ascorbic acid is an antioxidant
that protects the skin from damaging
free radicals that are made by UV
radiation and environmental pollution.
These are one of the main causes of skin
aging. The biggest problem with ascorbic
acid is that it breaks down in water
really quickly. If it's combined with
other antioxidants like vitamin E and
ferulic acid it breaks down way more
slowly, but this also tends to make the
product really expensive. I usually make
my own DIY vitamin C serum so I can make
sure it's fresh and save money. You can
also find more stable forms of vitamin C
in skin care like magnesium ascorbyl
phosphate and tetraisopalmitoyl
ascorbic acid, but there's a lot less
research on these.
Linoleic acid is a fatty acid that we usually find in
skincare oils. The difference between
linoleic acid and other acids is when
we're talking about linoleic acid in
oils, it's actually been reacted to lose
the acid group and it forms a
triglyceride,
so it won't donate H+. Linoleic acid by
itself can lighten pigmentation, but in
oils, most of the linoleic acid won't be
free to lighten your pigmentation like
it normally would. But it isn't entirely
useless in skincare oils. I personally
love oils that are rich in linoleic acid
because they tend to feel a lot lighter,
which is really nice when you have oily
skin like me. That's a quick overview of
my favorite skincare acids. Do you use
acids? Did I forget to talk about your
favourite one? Let me know in the comments!
If you liked this video please subscribe
to my channel, check out my blog, and
follow me on Instagram. I also have a
free exfoliation guide on my blog which
you might be interested in if you want
to find out more about acids. See you
next time for more beauty science! :)